And I know that the year 2024 as surely in this year
that we have just finished will touch me and not only me,
many more people.
"To strongly defend our own rights the rights we have as Spaniards the rights
of the citizens of my land rights that some want to shout ehr We are not
going to deceive ourselves there are people some very radical positions in
Spain that seek to scratch the Constitution that even seek to torpedo it" And
we will have to say loud and clear that it is true that the constitution
protects 1 plural Spain and I believe it is plural We are plural diversity is
wealth." completely prevents the privileges I VA to touch in this year 2 024
without a doubt me and many others I hope that with 1 Great social force
behind to defend something as elementary as that the equality of all
Spaniards is the other side of the same coin that is unity and equality are
the 2 great objectives that protects the Constitution and that
I will defend on behalf of all of you.